[Music]
[Music]
everybody welcome to the gambar podcast
my name is Brian Marcelo host in this
episode today very special guest the
scientist engineer author and lecture
and he has the great hypothesis wanna
share with you it's called the room
hypothesis it's going to explain to you
not just describe who's name right but
explain the workings and mechanisms of a
magnet and some other phenomena
mysterious phenomena such as light and a
whole bunch of other things before I
hurt myself look take it over no day
thank you for coming to the program
podcast thank you Bill
hey how you doing Brian
fantastic fantastic thank you explain to
us bill exactly how does magnets work
but we have to go back one take one step
backwards because that's going in the
middle of the story people might not
understand what's going on here the main
issue here is that you know we're
criticizing what the establishment does
and it's not very nice or people think
that everybody who attacks the
establishment is simply a wacko you know
he's out of his mind and he gets treated
that way you know you get a lot of other
I get a lot of rotten eggs thrown at my
face and you know and then I think
there's no room today for new theories
and that's part of the big problem and
I'm saying we have a problem with with
the interpretations of physical
interpretations of physics of all of
physics 100% of it specifically
everything dealing with invisible
entities or invisible phenomena light we
can't see it we don't nobody you know we
see light but every night we don't know
what light itself is we don't know what
what is doing this this magic we don't
know what magnetism
you mentioned magnets we don't know what
a magnetic field is made of we don't
know what gravity is you know we prop
everything you know you let go something
goes to the center of the earth or at
least to the fluorine but I think
everybody can vouch for that
and nobody knows what's pulling that pen
to the floor and so you know
mathematical physics has been trying to
find answers to these questions the last
at least 400 years we're talking about
since the 17th century are looking at
people like Newton and like this and and
OD games and so on and all these people
since in those days have been trying to
give an explanation to these things and
what we have today are irrational
explanations and I'm just going to give
you a quick example that puts it in the
correct light you know you need to have
two particles right and I have my little
props here every now and then right you
have two parts right and you can
consider these two atoms two balls
whatever you want to two rocks how does
this one pull it this one very simple
very simple problem this is the entire
universe right this is all there is this
is the entire system and I'm saying how
does this one pull what happen you
cannot do it with discrete particles I
cannot throw have this one throw stones
at this one embryo you know I think
that's straightforward and what I'm
saying is that you know all atoms in the
universe are interconnected that's my
starting point I'm saying that every
atom is interconnected now I can explain
if this is connected to that somehow
physically connected then yes when I
move this one as this one will move if I
if this one Falls this one move will be
dragged behind it now we can understand
action at a distance as long as we keep
them separate and throw stones and
between put little particles we can't do
that magic you know if you want to pull
out a donkey you got to tie a rope to
its neck and then you can pull it but
you can have
by throwing stones at mates I think that
straightforward way and the problem
mathematical physical factor fundamental
problem is that mathematical physics
tries to explain phenomena using
discrete particles and I'm saying that
the particle hypothesis has to once and
for all be abandoned it has to be thrown
in the ash heap of history and here I
have a loo which I presented last time
but if it gives you an idea what I'm
proposing if this is if this is what
mathematical physics proposes which is
on this side here saying all the
discrete particles I'm saying that all
atoms are interconnected okay
and I hope you can see that oh yes
something clear yes okay and so not only
are they connected but I'm saying how
are they connected I'm saying that what
connects any two atoms and we're talking
about the hydrogen atom here you know
the simplest of all atoms I'm saying
that all atoms are interconnected by a
rope not by a wave and it's not that an
atom throws away to another atom but
they're physically connected by a rope
and what light is is a portion of that
room you got a rope that I've made some
time ago okay and I'm saying it if you
think of my two fists as atoms right
right if that's what those fists are
atoms what an atom does during quantum
jump it expands and contracts right it
goes like this
it expands it it's a little balloon
that's expanding and contracting okay
what it does what it does is torque the
room and light is a torsion that travels
along the rope that's why it's
undulating you know and that's why
travels straight because this rope is
tight so we can explain many other
features now you can see why the
electric field in this case the thread
is 90 degrees to the
magnetic field and both of them embrace
and imaginary axis if you pull the rope
tight there is an accident that runs
right through the center of that rope
and so we the rope is a better model to
mimic or to simulate what we see with
life and now yes once you have that as a
foundation now you can explain
for example magnetism here I have two
little magnets that we all know this
magical ability is a bad day because we
can't see what it's doing even here here
you have two little magnets right and
let's do my business you know if you if
you hold them in if you hold up wrong
side see if you hold the magnet there
right you can see that it doesn't fall
so so you know it it does this magic and
in fact just before before I get there
you know you can do this on your own but
if we break it I can already see that
it's pulling up and Mike was if I turn
it around I can't put them together I
try to put them together they push each
other apart you know it's go sideways
you see that and we say well what is
this magic you know we can't see it so
how is Mother Nature doing this and I'm
saying if if you take I'm saying that
the physical mechanism is that these
ropes one of the threads comes loose you
got a rope right now I'm going to pull
one of the threads out okay so we have
this situation this one's tight the blue
one is tight and this one swings around
the blue one okay so this is turning at
great speeds and with what the ABS are
doing they're turning and they're
spinning one of the threads around the
other okay now if we have many of these
you have a wall of threads we say that's
the magnetic field how do we produce a
tragic how do we produce attraction and
repulsion well if one wall is going to
discretion and the other wall
is also going in the same direction
they're both going into the same
direction what this one comes up this
one comes down and it bolts imagine two
people skipping next to each other
what guy skips the other skips in the
same direction when this rope comes up
this rope comes down and this is the
same thing but with threads the threads
one of the threads of the rope comes
loose one comes up the other one comes
down and so they do this and that's
where it pulls you turn the magnet it
around this web right for example and
now they're going like this now they're
pushing each other away and now the more
threads that intervene the harder it is
to put them together because there are
more threads pushing against each other
that's saying I'm saying that's what's
happening with the magnets the bottom
line is we have a different explanation
for light magnetism gravity and it's
very hard to get it out there because
the majority of people already have
bought into the particle hypothesis that
mathematical physics cells and we're
thinking with that that's got to change
or would that's right that's we were
working on yeah yeah I love your own
hypothesis it's easy for the average
person out of here you know understand
because it's something that we see in
our everyday lives some of those other
ideas you can illustrate it you know I
mean one of the good things about the
rope model is that you can illustrate
everything is illustrative all the guy
only has to watch the movie and the
point the point of it is not for him to
believe to say oh yes you've convinced
me now the issue is do you understand
the mechanism I promote let me
understand you understood it we're done
with science whether you believe it or
not that's a separate issue I call that
religion its opinion you know whether
you like this theory or the other
theories at your
personal opinion the ubii issue is can
you understand the mechanism that I'm
proposing and that's when we have
science you know you might have a
different mechanism fine you know
compare mechanism but the issue is to
understand and ethically not to not to
be convinced or be recruited or
converted the others there's one thing
on and just reading the comments on the
various pages that you had I see is some
confusion where people were trying to
wrap their minds around these threads
now one of them trying to see what I
tried to do was to actually shrink
myself down to around the size of the
threads and at a man there you go and
what I'm trying what I'm trying to see I
think when people looking at it
they see a crisscross of threads all
over the place so in their minds it
might make I don't know if there's a
color associated with that but it seems
like it just blankets everything and
maybe you can't separate the individual
thread so I tried to shrink myself down
to one roughly the size if maybe I can
see the individual thread so to speak
how was that is everything all blanketed
enough on the same is properly but is
everything all blanketed with threads
you know saying oh well I'm saying that
if every atom in the universe right is
connected by a rope no electromagnetic
growth right which just just as on the
side here which is where DNA gotta
change the shape of DNA is a rope is it
twisted rope and I'm saying DNA copies
light and but that's just an aside here
but if you can either the two atoms if
they're connected by a rope mm-hmm you
know and we just go with that simple
model which is already quite
accomplished itself okay
on the one hand and symmetric also to to
balloons united by road as a simple
simple and symmetric system you know and
we first must understand that because if
we're going to go into you know how
gravity works when you have many ropes
pulling on something or you're talking
about you know for example the earth is
connected to the Sun and I'm saying
every atom on the earth is connected to
every atom that comprises aside that
means each from what I'm here you have a
rub gun too you know and Adam over there
and so you know here I have little props
here you know you can think of that as
the many ropes ok and what the Sun does
essentially is you know throw the earth
around that's what the Sun does now we
can understand it because there's a
physical connection every atom here to
every atom in the Sun but the end of the
the official model you cannot explain
that because you know you have to invent
either particles which don't work
particles and what general relativity
has done is say well space is a physical
object time is a physical object we put
them together we create a
four-dimensional object and they warp it
into some kind of bowl who let and the
earth goes around it so that's the
mechanism that's the physical
interpretation and general relativity
offers and you know those are maybe
simple all these are simple - when you
just look at that but yeah when you get
into the nitty-gritty instead of very
very complicated yeah exactly exactly we
spoke about that point you know we spoke
about the user it spoke about the ether
last time and the right and I mentioned
like perhaps these threads that are all
over connecting all of these various
atoms perhaps that's the background in
the ether that people speak up or detect
we speak yeah
you know the word ether I've given a
little presentation that I channel the
other day and and the word either has
been around for us you know since the
base of the Greece it means and you've
never really offended the the ether in
one way or another there's always this
invisible whatever that we call ether
and used to be the the medium that was
undulating that were vibrating and they
said well light is the vibration of the
ether Einstein comes in he says no it's
space-time but space-time essentially is
a medium and you know you essentially
treat it as a medium and that's the
ether of today so you get into quantum
mechanics and they'll tell you that
particles come in they pop in from the
four virtual particles and that's
another ether what is the cosmic
background radiation either it's all
ether concept what does the same thing
and I'm saying yeah that sense the the
countless four ropes that you if you had
God's eyes you know you can see
everything that's invisible we can see
all these ropes connected in every atom
and that's what we're sensing with the
equipment and that is the background
radiation and that's the ether that's in
the background exactly you know I'm
gonna point that right before we would
go on would you tell people where you
can check out your material on like your
lectures on you various some videos and
a little bit about the rational mind
page on Facebook that would well I'm
giving presentations in picture and
anybody can locate it to look for
rational science and also I have the
these lectures on YouTube and they can
locate them there under the same name
rational science and then we have a
Facebook that's not handled by me
but I'm just one of the members and it's
called also rational scientific method
and that's on Facebook so you know these
are different forms where we go into and
we discuss these issues we try to
discuss them from a rational point of
view try to make sense of how this
universe works and that's what all these
forms really do you know what the
problem makes sense of this and not to
say well you know we don't know and you
know particles attract particles and by
magic and we have works space-time and
things that nobody can imagine yes a
[ __ ] it in and we also campaign
against what we call call or consider
nonsense black holes dark matter all
these you know entities that they've
invented are conveniently heavy and
invisible yeah you had notice that every
time also convenient yeah I mean from a
mathematical point of view a you can say
yeah if you have a lot of mass you don't
care what it looks like you could look
like an elephant but the important thing
is that you you're concerned about the
mass because that's what you're going to
put in your equation and we're saying
that's mathematics now bring that into
physics what are we talking about what
physical object and all the objects are
conveniently invisible and then a lot of
them single exams you'll never see never
see up you'll never see a black hole but
it will always have to infer it
indirectly by watching something that's
visible ah he says yeah a lot of these
days that they come up with they seem
like patches are afterthoughts you know
they run into a stumbling block you know
with the theory or hypothesis and like I
say they have to create something you
know like for instance why doesn't dum
the Galaxy scrying part well there's
that one might be some dark matter or
something or someone that you know
exactly this stuff yeah and yeah and
that's what they do
if you look at how they how they came up
with dark matter for those who go you
know I'm not familiar with the subject
now they looked at the galaxy and they
find out that the galaxies on the
outside of the stars on the outside of
the galaxy travel at the same speed or
even faster than some on the inside
close to the center Wow and imagine
imagine message of two runners on a
track right you got our circular track
we all know that the guy on the inside
the guy who's got the inside track you
know ain't gonna go faster than the guy
on the outside because you get less you
know that's the guy on the outside goes
faster you know you kind of say well I
can explain that
and that's the case of you no matter
what they did they sprinkled all this
heavy and miserable kilograms on the
outside of the galaxy now see now we can
explain yeah time flies fast you were so
worried about these podcasts
time goes by super quick and we're like
really there and then they're ready
is there anything that you like speak to
the people about or anything like tell
them before we in the spot gasps oh now
you keep an open mind people should
should be aware that most of the
theories today if you're gonna propose a
new theory you're not going to be able
to get it published because the
publishing world is governed by the
people who already went through the
through through college and they've been
brainwashed with with the old theories
and so the whole the whole world of
mathematics you know these people
believe in all these things in my calls
and dark matter and that particles
through all these magical things and
that virtual particles coming from the
void and they do it all mathematically
but they can't do it physically they
can't show me in the lab they can't even
put it on the screen for me and so what
I'm saying is if people really want to
have an open mind and think a little bit
outside the box doesn't mean to have to
believe it but if you want to stimulate
your mind you know one good place is to
go outside of the mainstream and find
out what's out there and again you know
since it's very hard to publish you're
gonna find a lot of the stuff today in
this day and age I'm used to in places
like paint challenge but you're gonna
have to just find a place that deals
with this subject or these subjects
right from a different angle and that's
what I'm saying you know people should
visit these sites and they'll get a
different a different view of the
universe no doubt about exactly yeah
they said the establishment they have it
they're all gonna fire a horse in the
race
they got skin in the game you know they
got things to protect I understand well
I published articles but it's very hard
to bubble it's already hard to publish
and one of the reasons is that he would
be careful you can't start your paper
like saying like I'm gonna show them in
this article in this paper that form the
mechanics is nonsense you just can't
start at noon you gotta be very subtle
and say look guys here's I'm proposing
something different I intend they know
what he was talking thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us in the
podcast yeah thank you so much for your
hypothesis that rope hypothesis that
your mind oh definitely it's done and
another thing on what I love about it is
that the average person out here will be
able to understand physics and perhaps
you get more involved in I like that so
much and I appreciate you so much bill
thank you so much just as a final
important area I always say physics is
for kids
it's like tricks none of the
kids should be among infant mathematics
propias now
yeah yeah right I appreciate you so much
ladies and gentlemen they locate even
the rope hypothesis thank you so much
bill what do you do that thank each and
every one of you checking out the end of
our podcast join us again next time and
check out our past episodes awesome once
again my name is Brian Morris on hosting
this episode you have our podcast and
remember yeah my podcast is a place
where you make it happen
please thank you so much bill
[Music]
[Music]